welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new doctor strange 2 video
all about ghostwriter there was a new
report that we might see him during
multiverse of madness so i'll explain
what's going on with that what that
might look like
and there's even some new reports about
the villain of doctor strange too so
we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos
we'll actually be getting that first
doctor strange 2 trailer later this year
really excited to see what sam raimi did
with his take on the movie
but recently if you didn't see the news
the hashtag show people are claiming to
have personally seen
concept art from doctor strange to
multiverse of madness showcasing
a new version of ghostwriter that
they're claiming is the johnny blaze
version of the character
there's already a pretty deep connection
between the ghost rider character
in the mcu and what they were doing on
one division with the dark hold and
what's happening with that during doctor
strange too so i'll explain those
connections in a second
we also already know the movie is going
to be direct crossover with spider-man 3
no way home
not only is it the next marvel movie
right after spider-man 3 but doctor
strange benedict cumberbatch himself
is a big character during spiderman no
way home and there were some easter eggs
on the set
that seemingly referenced some of the
things that they were trying to set up
back during one division
that doesn't mean that scarlet witch is
going to show up during spider-man no
way home they might reference something
in a post-credits scene
if we're talking about spider-man 3
teasing doctor strange to stuff and
characters i think it's mostly just
going to be through benedict
cumberbatch's character
it's just that they're rolling so hard
on the multiverse trope and that's what
they were starting to set up at the end
of one division in that post-credits
scene
but we do know that scarlet witch's
storyline will be one of the major
forces driving the plot in doctor
strange too
they did a pretty good job of teasing
what was going on with that during the
one division post credit scene
vague as it may have been they did
clarify a few things since then
wanda takes off at the end of the finale
and went into hiding according to the
showrunner and also elizabeth olsen
tried to explain that herself so that no
one would be able to find her and hold
her accountable for what she did in west
view there was a big joke about that
like she just takes off without saying
she's sorry
they said she did that so that they
wouldn't hold her to task and so people
like dr strange
wouldn't stop her or try to take the
darkhold from her
so metaphorically and literally wanda
goes off the map to learn everything
that she can from the darkhold which
obviously is one of the most dangerous
books that she has
agatha harkness was trying to tell her
that during the finale like you're going
to need me
for what's coming that's all about the
prophecy that she's supposed to bring
about the end of the world that's inside
the dark hole so she not only wants to
learn about that prophecy
she also wants to learn more about the
nature of chaos magic and then she gets
the big teaser
that her children might be in another
dimension trapped somewhere so she's
also
going to try and use the dark hole to
find them so in wanda messing with chaos
magic the multiverse the dark hole that
sort of sets the stage for the villain
of doctor strange too to take advantage
and come into the main mcu dimension
which is exactly what doctor strange is
trying to prevent that's dr strange's
whole job is protecting the main mcu
reality
from threats from other dimensions from
other realities
we also just learned about that deleted
doctor strange storyline and all the
deleted scenes that we're going to
feature benedict cumberbatch's character
they said the plan originally was to
have doctor strange's character be the
one to create all those fake commercials
during the episodes and he was supposed
to have been using them to try and
communicate with wanda
inside the hex and get her to realize
what was happening and warn her about
act of the harkness so
make all the jokes you want doctor
strange knew that it was agatha all
along
then he would have appeared in the
finale to teach her about her chaos
magic and then i believe the
post-credits scene would have still been
the same like her stealing the darkhold
and taking off before doctor strange
could take it into safe keeping so that
she could read from it learn more about
her magic and then try to use it to find
a way to bring her children billy and
tommy back
as you hear them crying out there
there's also the idea of wanda as a
nexus being as they were trying to tease
in that last big commercial
not only is she a nexus being but
there's also the idea of the concept of
the nexus
of the multiverse like the gateway to
all realities all dimensions
but i think one of the reasons why we're
probably hearing about ghost writer
references
possibly being in doctor strange too is
because kevin feige said a long time ago
that one of the things that excited him
so much about the doctor strange
character
was that he was the gateway to the
supernatural characters in the mcu
he said doing the supernatural stories
through the doctor strange movies is the
major reason why
now they can do the blade movie and they
have a justification to logically
explain
how vampires can exist in the mcu
alongside captain america and iron man
the other characters
there were a lot of you asking why they
didn't include the blade movie in that
last big marvel phase 4 trailer but i
think the idea
is that just a little further off in the
development of that and it will come at
some point after the fantastic four
movie like late
2023 unless there's some big delay they
run into in the next year or so
another great example of a supernatural
character that they're doing now
that we'll see next year is the mark
spectre moon knight character in that
disney plus series he's being played by
oscar isaac i'm sure it's gonna be
fantastic series and if we're talking
about blade the darker characters
dracula obviously big vampire character
that everybody knows about is a big moon
knight crossover villain
there's no hard release date for the
moon night series right now i think it's
supposed to drop sometime
next spring i'll do more videos about
that when they release more information
you probably saw the behind the scenes
video that oscar isaac posted of him
training for his fight
scenes he will be hardcore during that
series but is bringing it back around to
the ghost rider character
he's a character you could totally use
in darker disney plus series or future
supernatural movies like the blade
sequels
in fact talking more about the one
division and doctor strange two
connections if you watched agents of
shield the ghostwriter character the
spirit of vengeance already has a deep
connection to the things that are going
on
in those stories through the darkhold
itself they did a version of the
darkhold during agents of shield season
4 as part of their ghost rider storyline
now the ghost writer that they did was
mostly the robbie reyes version
but they did a bunch of different
iterations of the character so they
teased the johnny blaze version and the
dandy catch versions but coulson
also got to have the spirit of vengeance
like coulson ghostrider mack
so he was another version of ghost rider
during the series
you get to be ghostwriter you get to be
ghostwriter everybody in the audience
gets to be ghostwriter
the version of the darkhold that they
did on agents of shield looked a little
bit different like they gave it a big
time upgrade for one division just to
make it look more like one of the books
of magic that you would see inside the
doctor strange movies
but in the comics the darkhold was
written by c'thon he's the god of chaos
the most powerful of the elder gods and
he's also the source of
all chaos magics that's why wanda has
chaos magic is because he made it that
way
it seemed that they were trying to tease
him through the dark hold in the one
division finale
implying that maybe he was trying to
manipulate wanda using her children in
that post-credit scene like he might be
trying to trick wanda into bringing him
to the main mcu dimension
but you all remember the mephisto jokes
the funnier connection here just because
of all the mephisto
jokes that were going around during one
division is that mephisto the character
was actually the person in the comics
who bonded the spirit of vengeance to
johnny blaze in the first place
that doesn't mean that mephisto is gonna
suddenly show up when ghost rider shows
up in the mcu eventually
they change the comic book stories all
the time and there are weird
considerations about what they can and
can't do
inside china i know there's always a
question about that but with all the
stuff happening in the mcu connecting
all these dots it's just a funny
coincidence
i've also heard a rumor recently about
schumacher goreth possibly being the
villain of doctor strange too
he's been a long time big doctor strange
villain in the comics if you're not
familiar with the character
he's like an extra dimensional being
who's a boss level upgrade from dormammu
like we talk about the nightmare
character we talk about mephisto we talk
about dormammu
mcgorth is kind of like their boss he's
another one of the eldritch lores sort
of exists in his own dimension he talks
about being from outside of all
existence from the void of nothingness
outside existence
but one of the names that shumagorth
goes by in the comics is also
lord of chaos so because conceptually
he's a much
easier villain to swallow than say like
c'thon also much easier to pronounce his
name than pronouncing cathode's name
what marvel might wind up doing just to
simplify things to the cliffs notes
version is changing the backstory of the
darkhold in the mcu to make it so that
schumacheth
is the one who wrote it and have him be
the source of wanda's chaos magic if
they're calling him the lord of chaos
and i believe early on scott derrickson
even said that he thought about using
schumachorth as the villain of the first
doctor strange movie before they settled
on dormammu
it's just that shumagorth is so powerful
that you think that they would save him
for like the last doctor strange movie
if they're going to do a trilogy of
movies eventually
but if we're talking about escalating
things in marvel phase 4 and if doctor
strange 2 is meant to be one of the
biggest marvel phase 4 movies he would
definitely be a threat that's just as
big if not bigger than thanos
theoretically
cannot wait to hear spider-man
wisecracking about a giant
octopus-looking creature floating in the
sky with a huge eyeball
so just don't be surprised if they do
wind up combining the cathode in the
schumacherth characters in the mcu
as for who they would get to play their
new version of ghost rider in the mcu
new version of johnny blaze i know a lot
of people would love to see keanu reeves
be their new version of johnny blaze
right around the time the avengers end
game was coming out kevin feige did
admit that they were meeting with him
about a project in the mcu but he also
said that they met with keanu reeves
during every big marvel phase
just about new projects that he might be
a fit for and which characters he was
interested in
and the reason why you haven't seen him
in the mcu yet playing a character is
because they haven't found the right
character for him yet that he connects
with on a fundamental level
but everyone let me know in the comments
who do you want to be the new version of
johnny blaise
rider when he eventually does show up in
a new marvel project they did have a
ghost rider tv show they were going to
do with the robbie reyes version from
agents of shield it was going to be like
a spin-off
with his version of the character but
when kevin feige took over all the
marvel television shows they basically
canceled that ghost rider tv
show and now the way gabrielle luna
talks about it the actor he says he
doesn't expect to ever come back as that
character
so it does sound like when they
introduce a new ghostwriter it'll be a
completely new version of the character
with a totally different actor
but if we hear any more news about
what's going on with that or any new
doctor strange 2 news of course i'll do
a video about it
but while you wait for everything click
here for my big marvel phase 4
trailer video in my eternals trailer and
you can click here for my brand new
venom let there be carnage trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight